a leak aitikaf former professional  fighter gave it up for the dean you got  a nice beard there brother do people  ever teach you about it yeah my country  that people always ask me so oh why he  brought such a big beard the beard is  dirty you look at this you look like a  caveman I'd say yeah this doesn't make  no sense because every one of you have  this little picture of the guy with a  big beard and you worship Him Acoma God  he's the most religious man in your eyes  when I carry a beer as the dirty this  doesn't make no sense  Daniel a seafood yeah that's a good  point look people make fun of the  Muslims with the beard and then Jesus  one of the greatest messages ever sent  to mankind they end up worshipping Him  as a god but he had a beard  have you ever thought about that think  about that intent  until then we'll keep the beers go sell  illegal